[Music]
why don't you do me the first word that
comes to mind when you think of each
other [ __ ] [ __ ]
well he's drawn the same page that's
good all right let's try this
name one thing you both like on each
other she's good at taxes aah
looking for something a bit more
personal he doesn't like the girl more
girls I think that's a pretty likable
thing I want to talk about your son he's
five he's actually six according to the
file I was gonna ask you about his
behavior but you know what love to
change gears how often you both have sex
masturbation counts three uh I mean not
really no I'd say a couple times a week
is not just weekends counts all right
we're out of time let's pick up again
next week and in the meantime want you
both to give each other three
compliments before our next session
that's easy right is that a trick
question yeah I don't understand the
question
for the park so make some friends man
five he doesn't have kids my friends
because you what are you talking what
I'm talking about to you how you acting
if he's cute
what are you saying look I work hard
punching numbers while you get stoned
and get lost in the beyond section of
your stupid store okay first of all who
cares about the stone I'm doing
inventory you'd want to be stoned - all
right
you're just an over glorified accountant
great crazy guys figure you play with
pill shrimp get out of here hey mom I'm
fine honey
yeah have fun I pay the bills and maybe
you would notice that if you're spending
all your after-hours your creepy friend
chick chick is my manager yeah I'm a
manager yes of Bed Bath and Beyond
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what what is he doing playing with it
it's spongebob have you ever seen the
cartoon spongebob yeah he's a spawn this
is way to Milan toys like this it's just
[Music]
hey could you do these kids look alive
pretty fresh all your fault
maybe amazing shut up
let's go can you snap that kids femur
good job Michael yeah well you both look
good oh yeah we worked it out and we're
opening up our own business well that's
great together
no I'm opening my own tea shop Oh coffee
shop
well he's healthier and I won't be
riddled with hipsters G is for [ __ ]
and we won't be riddled with those I
mean unless mr. Lipton decides to stop
by and see his wife
these two could operate together in cats
right all good okay let's talk about oh
I got a hand job in the car that's
getting somewhere
and Michael where is he right
he's in school it's 16
yeah Jesus Christ I've never met two
bigger moronic [ __ ] [ __ ] in my
life
Who am I to judge
sorry was not great grand wonderful
sentiment
[Music]